Marvel famously plays their cards close
to the vest when it comes to keeping
story details secret both to avoid
spoilers and to keep pants guessing but
the studio has revealed some unexpected
characters set to appear in its next big
film here's a look at some of the most
surprising characters confirmed for
Avengers endgame and obviously some
major potential spoilers ahead portrayed
by Tilda Swinton in 2016 s Doctor
Strange the ancient one was Steven
Strange's mentor who taught the eventual
sorcerer supreme everything he knows
about magic and the mystic arts in the
film it's revealed that she'd been using
dark magic to lengthen her life she
draws power from the dark dimension to
stay alive that's not true I've seen the
rituals work the man
soon after in a savage battle with
villain K Silius the ancient one is
mortally wounded and dies but not before
a final heart-to-heart with strange via
astral projection while death isn't
always the end of the road in superhero
movies the images of the Ancient Ones
vanishing astral projection seemed as
final an outcome as one can receive in
the MCU
that's exactly why many fans were
surprised to see Swinton's name on end
games IMDB page following her death dr.
strange wielded the artifact known as
the eye of agamotto which was revealed
to be the time stone the Ancient Ones
reappearance has fueled fan theories
that time travel will play a major role
in endgame in the first act of infinity
war Wong joins the fight against the
invading black order once dr. strange is
kidnapped however Wong abruptly exits
the remainder of the film's action to
protect the sanctum sanctorum while
Wong's fate post snap is never fully
revealed the actor has confirmed his
participation in endgame assuming this
means that Wong is alive and well this
character could wind up being
surprisingly crucial to the plot right
into my wedding
dr. strange is conspicuously left out of
the confirmed cast for endgame when last
we saw him an infinity war he was
disintegrating to dust while also
hinting at a larger plan in dr. strange
long was the keeper of the mystical
library and kamar taj and was
responsible for schooling strange on the
nature of the time stone encased within
the eye of agamotto as perhaps the last
hero standing with in-depth knowledge of
the Infinity stones and significant
experience wielding the time stone Wang
may be the one to bring benedict
cumberbatch back to the endgame call
sheet after all remember back in Iron
Man 3 when Tony Stark wound up in the
garage of young Harley keener
don't move
while the character served a narrative
of Iron Man 3 and comedic sensibilities
of director Shane Black what place could
this kid now a teenager possibly have an
endgame
with rampant speculation that end game
could be Robert Downey jr. Spinal MCU
appearance certain theories suggest that
keener could make an appearance for Tony
Stark's funeral others theorized that
stark could be looking to pass the torch
and perhaps keener could be in line for
the Iron Man mantle nearly every one of
the guardians of the galaxy perished an
infinity war only rocket remains of the
core group star-lord Drax mantis and
Groot were all taken in the culling
it seems the Infinity Gauntlet effected
an unfair percentage of guardians until
you remember that star-lord totally blew
it on Titan
maybe that's why he's the only one of
these characters not listed on end games
IMDB page mantis Groot and Drax are all
confirmed to be appearing according to
that cast list Gamora was also killed by
Thanos an infinity war though not by the
snap instead she was offered as a
sacrifice on planet Vermeer by Thanos in
order to acquire the soul stone we do
see Gamora one more time in infinity war
however once Thanos has completed his
goal of wiping out half the life in the
universe with the Infinity Gauntlet he
appears in a dreamlike dimension
confronted by a young Gamora the scene
is bathed in an eerie orange light the
same color as the soul stone speaking to
children at Iowa City City High
co-director John Russo confirmed that
this scene actually takes place within
the stone or perhaps a pocket dimension
created by it
if Gamora is in this purgatory place
within the soul stone is it possible
that other dusted characters are also
within the orange realm despite their
apparent deaths in ant-man in the wasp
current and former wasps hope and Janet
Van Dyne are both listed on endgames
IMDB though notably Hank Pym isn't on
the list according to Peyton Reed who
directed ant-man in the wasp his films
timeline was left intentionally
ambiguous we liked the idea of the
structure where and true ant-man style
everyone has closure and everything's
tied together and almost in too neat of
a bow at the end then - bang give the
audience a gut punch right after the
main credits that felt like our movies
tone and the way of dealing with that in
that credit sequence just before Scott
pops into the quantum realm
Janet gives him a potentially loaded
warning and don't get sucked into a time
vortex we won't be able to save you
could Scott Lang stuck in the quantum
realm possibly find a way to access
different points of time using a vortex
actor Frank Grillo has confirmed that
crossbones makes an appearance an
endgame the bony bad guy hasn't appeared
in the MCU since the opening sequence of
2016's Captain America Civil War when he
detonated a bomb on himself speaking
during a podcast interview with UFC
unfiltered Grillo said he makes an
appearance in the next Avengers movie
but it's a flashback
what's interesting here is Grillo's use
of the term flashback crossbones his
appearance may very well be a standard
narrative flashback but it could also be
a lot more given all the time-travel
rumors surrounding not only in the time
stone but ant-man and the wasps mid
credit sequence that leaves ant-man
stuck in the quantum realm we all know
Spidey is due back for his second solo
MCU film and spider-man far from home
however considering that the last time
we saw Peter Parker he wasn't feeling so
good it's still kind of surprising to
see his name listed with the confirmed
cast evidently something gets Peter
Parker back from the great beyond in
time for his field trip and far from
home but fans believe that the trailer
for far from home hints at the death of
another character an end game Tony Stark
not only is stark completely absent from
the far from home trailer but some say
spider-man's decision not to bring his
Spidey suit with him on his trip is
further evidence of Iron Man's demise
and Peter's need to get some distance
from that greeting of all the terrible
downfalls that occurred in infinity war
perhaps nobody had a harsher demise than
Wanda Maximoff aka Scarlet Witch Wanda
uses her powers to pull the mine stone
from visions head and destroy it
however pano spoils her sacrifice by
using the time stone to rewind time and
just get the stone anyway on top of that
the snap turns Scarlet Witch to dust
just a few moments later despite all
that Elizabeth Olsen is slated to
reprise her role in
game according to Olson her situation
won't improve speaking on a panel at ace
comic-con in Chicago
Olson cryptically warned that it was
only going to get worse
Sebastian Stan's Winter Soldier and his
friendship with Chris Evans as Captain
America has been an emotional fulcrum
for the MCU narrative in recent years
and Captain America Civil War the fight
between cap and Tony was much deeper and
much more personal than politics
it took the bigger debates of the
sokovia accords and boiled it down to
fighting for the soul of Bucky Barnes
with Bucky reduced to ash and infinity
war how to Sebastian Stan find himself
back for endgame his Winter Soldier
appearing on The Late Late Show with
James Corden the host asks Stan if he
could explain how he came back for
Avengers endgame Stan had a coy reply of
recording [ __ ] he's dead Happy New Year
well that's that's that's it that's all
I got darn these Marvel secrets check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]